as we make our way to the end of 2022
we're counting down some of our favorite
songs of the Year by queer artists and
dare I say that 2022 was the most queer
year ever I dare
[Music]
to kick things off we have everyone's
favorite bisexual Brazilian queen that's
right I'm talking about Anita the global
pop Superstars massive hit involver
climbed its way to number one on the
Billboard's Global chart all thanks to
the success of its Tick Tock viral dance
[Music]
we caught up with Anita who expressed
the key to confidence is to learn to be
your own source of Happiness if I didn't
feel like
amazing nobody would feel
[Music]
next up we have Demi Lovato now Demi has
been making hits for years and years and
certainly never misses the mark when it
comes to delivering some major box Demi
released her latest album holy F which
included the hit track substance I love
this track
foreign
[Music]
this next artist has been breaking
barriers and has been Paving the way for
future queer rappers and he looks damn
good doing it of course I'm talking
about Lil Nas X
while on his Long Live Montero tour Lil
Nas X revealed that he would be teaming
up with League of Legends as their new
honorary president with the Game's new
Anthem star walk-in
[Music]
at second place it's former Disney
Channel star Dove Cameron with her Smash
Hit boyfriend
yeah aniti Canada caught up with Dove
ahead of the release of boyfriend and
she teased what fans can expect from her
upcoming music you know boyfriend is
obviously a queer song
um it's very like that you know it's
very me and it was it was the very first
song that I sat down and wrote with Ed
now before we rank our number one spot
we have to shout out some of our
favorite queer artists who dropped new
music this year from Omar Apollo Daya
Panic at the Disco Haley Kyoko m e k Ben
Platt Kilani and of course Canadians
Tegan and Sarah who released their 10th
studio album Cry Baby 10th studio album
come on I looked up other bands I had 10
albums out because I was like you know
is this like a normal thing it's not a
departure but it's definitely a return
in a way to some of the things we've
done in the past
[Music]
now drum roll please
in our number one spot is that song that
dominated the charts yes I'm talking Sam
Smith and Kim petrus's Unholy yeah Sam
and Kim made history when the track
reached number one on the billboard hot
100. Sam became the first non-binary
artist and Kim the first openly
transgender artist to top of the chart
listen we stand these two at E.T Canada
congratulations Sam and Kim
[Music]
doing something
hey thanks for watching ET Canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos